have you been considering pulling the
trigger on that million dollar business
idea you've got a killer product and
genius marketing plan but what about the
finances legal and tax tough LLC's
partnerships DBAs escorts ah this add
truth is too many people put off
implementing a good idea in the proper
way because they're intimidated but fear
not we've got you covered and it's
probably not as complicated or as costly
as you might think
so let's get our business building
blocks out and see what goes into
building a business the right way the
first step is to put on your CFO hat and
get to work setting up your finances
correctly do you need to set up a
business bank account or is a personal
checking okay if you're just starting
out experts agree that the most
important thing is to separate your
business money from your personal money
completely no leaks it will help you
avoid bookkeeping and tax headaches
before they start and when you're just
starting out using a separate personal
checking account can be fine but
eventually upgrading to a business
checking account can offer special
benefits like additional protection of
your personal assets if things go south
all of your initial setup costs like a
website or logo design should come from
this account and not your personal one
it will also eventually be the
destination for income once those
Benjamins start rolling in now it's time
to decide on a legal structure if your
business is on the smaller side you've
got some simpler options like the sole
proprietorship a sole proprietor
business has one owner you and is not a
separate entity under the law if this is
your choice you won't have to file
anything with the government to get
started but you may be personally held
responsible for any debts the business
might incur and come tax time all the
profit or loss from the business will
run through your personal tax return you
can operate the business under your own
personal name or you can choose to use
ADB
or doing business as for instance when I
had a professional organizing business I
wanted my clients to be able to make
checks out to Swiss Miss organizing
rather than my name it just felt more
professional but before I could get a
business account called Swiss Miss
organizing I had to file a DBA for that
name this is done at the county level
and most counties allow for a pretty
easy online filing process there will
most likely be filing fees but it's
usually under a hundred bucks if you
decide to share ownership of a business
with at least one other person then
you'll need to form a partnership it
might be worth it to hire a small
business attorney to help you draft up
an agreement the money you spend will be
well worth it to have clarity of
ownership and operating agreements small
business partnerships implode all the
time due to vague or non-existent
contracting partnerships require not
only a DBA but also an electronic
identification number easily obtained
from the IRS website this acts like a
social security number for your business
and will allow you to file a tax return
for the business itself but the business
doesn't pay income tax instead it passes
through any profits or losses to its
partners meaning the partners are
personally on the hook for any taxes or
legal troubles if that sounds scary you
might want to consider a limited
liability company the LLC shields the
partners from most legal
responsibilities and protects their
personal assets should a client sue the
business for some reason putting an LLC
in place can cost a few hundred to a few
thousand dollars depending on your state
and whether you hire a professional to
help you that can increase the cost a
bit but it's better than finding out too
late that you're not protected because
it was improperly set up keep in mind
that the advantages here are for legal
protection only LLC's don't change how
the partners are taxed for that you need
to go one more step up eight corporation
the most common type for small business
owners is the subchapter S corporation
unlike all the other arrangements we've
talked about an S corp is considered by
the government to be its own
Griet entity both for legal and a tax
related purposes instead of just
absorbing the profits or losses your
business now pays you as an employee
and/or owner and because this income is
taxed at a different rate it can mean
some real savings but there are costs
associated with filing for an S corp and
they can get pretty hefty there's filing
charges an additional tax return you'll
have to get prepared and likely ongoing
charges for a payroll service it may all
be worth it for the tax savings you've
got or not to know for sure you should
speak with a tax specialist which brings
us to our final building block get some
experts in your corner any small
business owner will tell you that when
it comes to laws and taxes one simple
mistake can lead to massive headaches
down the road
selecting the right business entity is
just one of the many critical decisions
they can help you with when you're just
starting out we really recommend
building a relationship with a good CPA
bookkeeper and small business attorney
it's their job to help you make smart
decisions while still playing by the
rules building a small business might
feel daunting at first but if you take
your time
do your research and set things up right
from day one you'll be reaching your
dreams before you know it and that's our
two cents soundfield is a new music
education show from PBS Digital Studios
that explore some music theory
production history and culture behind
our favorite songs and musical styles
pop classical rap jazz electronic folk
country and more sound field covers it
all hosted by two supremely talented
musicians Arthur L a Buckner and NAR a
soul every episode is one part video
essay and one part musical performance
so go subscribe to sound field link in
the description below if you've ever
formed a partnership LLC or S corp tell
us about your experience in the comments
you
[Music]